>>> THIS NEXT STORY IS JUST
INCREDIBLE.
IT REALLY SPEAKS TO THE POWER OF
A FATHER'S LOVE AND A TRUE
SPIRIT OF CHRISTMAS.
LISTEN TO THIS.
CHRIS KENNEDY WAS SENT RACIST
HATE MAIL JUST FOR PUTTING UP AN
INFLATABLE BLACK SANTA IN HIS
FRONT YARD.
WHY BUT INSTEAD OF GIVING IN TO
THE HATE, THAT SET CHRIS ON THE
PATH TO BECOMING A PROFESSIONAL
SANTA FOR HIS ENTIRE TOWN.
HE WANTS OTHERS TO DO THE SAME.
LET'S START AT THE BEGINNING,
THOUGH, AND THAT LETTER IN
CHRIS'S OWN WORDS.
>> PLEASE REMOVE YOUR NEGRO
SANTA CLASS YARD DECORATION.
YOU SHOULD NOT TRY TO DECEIVE
CHILDREN INTO BELIEVING THAT I
AM A NEGRO.
I AM A CAUCASIAN, WHITE MAN TO
YOU, AND HAVE BEEN FOR THE PAST
600 YEARS.
YOUR BEING JEALOUS OF MY RACE IS
NO EXCUSE FOR YOUR DISHONESTY.
BESIDES THAT, YOU ARE MAKING
YOURSELF A LAUGHING STOCK OF THE
NEIGHBORHOOD.
MAYBE YOU SHOULD MOVE TO A
NEIGHBORHOOD WITH THE REST OF
YOUR RACIST KIND.
YOURS TRULY, SANTA CLAUS.
AND IT CAME WITH THE PICTURE,
SANTA CLAUS WITH THE THUMBS
DOWN.
I BROUGHT THIS TO DO THIS HERE.
>> YEAH!
>> SO HARD TO LISTEN TO.
THAT WAS A CLIP FROM THE HBO MAX
DOCUMENTARY "SANTA CAMP" AND WE
ARE THRILLED TO WELCOME CHRIS
KENNEDY ON TO THE PROGRAM NOW.
SANTA CHRIS, IT'S SO NICE TO SEE
YOU ON THIS DAY.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
>> WELL, HO, HO, HO AND MERRY
CHRISTMAS TO YOU GUYS.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON.
>> MERRY CHRISTMAS BACK TO YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO START SAD AND
IT'S GOING TO HAVE A VERY HAPPY
ENDING.
TELL US MORE ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
AFTER YOU GOT THAT LETTER.
I LOVE THAT YOU KEPT YOUR
DIGNITY AND STOOD UP AGAINST
THESE HATEFUL WORDS.
>> WELL, AFTER I GOT THAT,
IMMEDIATELY THE -- I INITIALLY
RECORDED A FACEBOOK VIDEO.
IT WENT VIRAL AND THEN I WENT TO
THE -- YOU KNOW, IN THE WHOLE
PROCESS I WENT TO THE POLICE
STATION, I WENT TO THE POST
OFFICE, TO, YOU KNOW, DO ALL THE
PROPER REPORTING.
AND THEN PEOPLE WERE REACHING
OUT AND ONE OF MY MENTORS WAS
LIKE, HEY, WOULD YOU MIND TAKING
PICTURES OF SANTA WITH MY
GRANDDAUGHTERS AS A LET'S GET
BACK AT THEM AND IT SNOWBALLED
FROM THERE.
I TOOK PICTURES WITH HER, MY
DAUGHTER AND JUST DIFFERENT
FRIENDS AND FAMILY.
AND THEN A FEW MONTHS LATER IT
WAS REACHED OUT TO BY SOMEONE
FROM SANTA CAMP ASKING IF I
WOULD CONSIDER COMING TO LEARN
ABOUT BEING A PROFESSIONAL
SANTA.
>> SANTA CHRIS, I LOVE ALSO
HEARING THAT SOME OF YOUR
NEIGHBORS AFTER YOU GOT THAT
LETTER ALSO STARTED PUTTING UP
BLACK SANTAS OF THEIR OWN IN AN
ACT OF SOLIDARITY WITH YOU.
WE'RE SHOWING CLIPS FROM THE
SANTA CAMP DOCUMENTARY.
IT FOLLOWS THE NEW ENGLAND SANTA
SOCIETY AS THEY TACKLE A LACK OF
DIVERSITY.
WE'LL HAVE ANOTHER CLIP FOR YOU.
>> I'D BE GLAD IF YOU COULD GIVE
ME ANY HINTS.
I DON'T MEAN TO OFFEND YOU.
I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT.
I DIDN'T MEAN TO ASK YOU THAT.
>> NO, THAT'S FINE.
>> BEING THE ONLY PERSON OF
COLOR HERE, IT WAS DEFINITELY
LONELY AND AWKWARD TO SAY THE
LEAST.
>> SANTA CHRIS, IT SEEMS LIKE
THEY LEARNED AS MUCH FROM YOU AS
YOU DID FROM THEM.
>> YEAH, THAT'S ABSOLUTELY TRUE.
WE WERE ABLE TO, YOU KNOW --
SANTA CAMP IS ALL ABOUT
LEARNING.
I WAS ABLE TO LEARN DIFFERENT
THINGS FROM THEM AND I DYED MY
BEARD AND DIFFERENT WAYS TO
INTERACT WITH KID AND THEY WERE
ABLE TO JUST LEARN HOW MUCH
DIVERSITY ACTUALLY DOES MATTER,
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS FOR LITTLE
BLACK AND BROWN KIDS TO SEE
THEMSELVES REFLECTED IN NOT
ONLY, YOU KNOW, REGULAR MEDIA
BUT AS A CHARACTER SUCH AS
SANTA.
>> WE'VE HEARD, YOU KNOW, IN
PREVIOUS YEARS VERY
CONTROVERSIAL STATEMENTS FROM,
YOU KNOW, MEDIA PERSONALITIES
AND THE LIKE ABOUT WHAT SANTA'S
SKIN COLOR SHOULD BE.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS SANGTA
SANTA IS A FICTIONAL CHARACTER.
HE IS WHO WE WANT HIM TO BE.
I'M CURIOUS TO KNOW WHAT YOUR
DAUGHTER THINKS ABOUT SANTA AND
I'VE HEARD THAT ARE PEOPLE WHO
COME FROM HOURS AWAY JUST TO
MEET YOU.
>> YEAH.
SO WE KIND OF DO THIS AS A
FAMILY.
MY DAUGHTER IS MY ELF.
MY WIFE IS MRS. CLAUS.
MY FIRST REALLY BIG EVENT WAS
THE NORTHERN LIGHT VEST VAL AND
WE HAD A COME COME FROM
MISSISSIPPI.
I KNOW SHE HAD HER DAUGHTER COME
AND PICK HER UP AND THEY HAD
DRIVEN WELL OVER 300 MILES TO
COME AND VISIT.
AND, YOU KNOW, IT WAS -- I'M SO
GLAD THE CAMERA WASN'T ON ME
WHEN SHE AND I WERE TALKING
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, I TEARED UP
BECAUSE SHE WAS TELLING ME, YOU
KNOW, SHE WAS 80 YEARS OLD, 80
PLUS, AND SHE HAD NEVER SEEN A
BLACK SANTA AND IT WAS THAT
IMPORTANT TO HER TO COME AND
VISIT ME.
THE AMOUNT OF KIDS THAT I'VE HAD
SINCE BECOMING SANTA THAT ARE SO
HAPPY THAT SANTA LOOKS LIKE
THEM, ONE OF MY LITTLE KIDS HE
IS JUST LIKE SANTA, YOU'RE BROWN
LIKE ME AND WAS RUBBING MY HAND
AND WAS JUST SO HAPPY TO BE
THERE.
AND IT'S, YOU KNOW, IT'S THOSE
THINGS THAT PEOPLE DON'T SEE,
THE LITTLE MOMENTS WITH KIDS
WHERE THEY'RE TELLING YOU AND
GIVING YOU DIFFERENT WORDS OF
AFFIRMATION THAT YOU DON'T EVEN
KNOW THAT YOU HAVE NEED AS AN
ADULT TO KNOW THAT YOU'RE DOING
SOMETHING RIGHT, THAT'S HAVING
AN IMPACT ON THEM.
>> THAT'S AWESOME.
SANTA CHRIS, IN ANOTHER SANTA
CAM CLIP, YOU TALK ABOUT A
SADNESS THAT YOU FEEL THAT THERE
AREN'T MORE BLACK SANTAS OUT
THERE, BUT YOU HAVE TO KNOW THAT
THERE MAY BE PEOPLE THAT COME
ACROSS YOU AND WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH AND IT
MAKES THEM ANGRY FOR WHATEVER
REASON.
WHAT WOULD BE YOUR MESSAGE TO
THOSE FOLKS?
>> IF YOU'RE ANGRY AT SEEING A
BLACK SANTA, THEN YOU'RE NOT FOR
ME.
BUT I'M HERE FOR EVERYONE ELSE
WHO ENJOYS THE CHRISTMAS SPIRIT,
ENJOYS SEEING SANTA AND WANTS TO
SEE THEMSELVES REFLECTED.
I HOLD NO ILL WILL TOWARDS
PEOPLE WHO DON'T LIKE ME SEEING
SANTA.
I'M HERE FOR KID AND FAMILIES
WHO WANT TO SEE REPRESENTATION
AND JUST WANT TO HAVE A GOOD
TIME WITH CHRISTMAS.
THERE'S LITERALLY NOTHING WRONG
WITH SEEING SOMETHING, NOT
LIKING IT AND MOVING ON.
THAT'S WHAT THE PERSON THAT
WROTE THAT LETTER SHOULD HAVE
DONE.
IF THEY DIDN'T LIKE IT, THEY
SHOULD HAVE JUST MOVED OND AND I
WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN ON THIS
TRAJECTORY MORE THAN LIKELY.
I WOULD HAVE JUST STUCK TO DOING
THIS FOR MY FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
BUT THERE'S SADNESS IN THE FACT
THAT THERE'S NOT MORE BLACK
CHRISTMAS PERFORMERS BUT THERE'S
HOPE BECAUSE THERE ARE BECOMING
MORE.
I'VE MET A TON OF SANTAS THAT
ARE AMAZING PEOPLE AND HAVE BEEN
NOTHING BUT HELPFUL AND I THINK
THAT MOVING FORWARD THAT
DIVERSITY IS GOING TO TAKE HOLD
IN THE SANTA COMMUNITY BECAUSE,
YOU KNOW, THE WHITE SANTAS DON'T
ACTUALLY CARE ABOUT MORE PEOPLE
GETTING INTO IT.
THEY WANT MORE PEOPLE INTO IT.
THE MORE PEOPLE THAT ARE HERE,
THE BETTER IT IS.
THE MORE PEOPLE THAT ARE
PROFESSIONALLY TRAINED, THE
BETTER IT IS FOR OUR PROFESSION.
I THINK IT IS GREAT AND DOES
NOTHING BUT HELP FAMILIES.
>> AND MAKE CHRISTMAS THAT MUCH
MORE MAGICAL FOR FAMILIES OF ALL
DIFFERENT BACKGROUNDS.
THAT PERSON THAT SENT THAT YOU
HATEFUL MESSAGE, HE OR SHE
IRONICALLY JUST HELPED INCREASE
REPRESENTATION IN THE SANTA
WORLD, RIGHT?
BEFORE I LET YOU GO, I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU HAVE YOUR
OWN SPIN ON SANTA'S HO, HO, HO.
CAN WE HEAR THAT BEFORE WE GO?
>> ABSOLUTELY, BRO HO HO, MERRY
CHRISTMAS, THANK YOU ALL FOR
WATCHING TODAY.
I HAVE MY OWN SPIN.
MY SANTA CLAUSE STARTED OUT AT
SIX FOOT AND NOW I HAVE A
15-FOOT ONE IN MY YARD.
>> BRO, HO, HO, I TH